was machst du da ich dreh durch der
flugschanze kohler maßnahmen diskussion
sorgen
kapitel 1 das versteht kein mensch aber
ich kann nicht immer nur rumsitzen kein
kino kein sport ich werde ich es seit
wochen nur noch dinge die ich selber
gekocht habe dass das kann wird doch
nicht gebaut haben
nein das was die politik da beschließt
kinos restaurants zu aber alle fahrer
mit der u-bahn zur arbeit haben wir mal
einen erklärt halo hat hier jemand
erklären gesagt gott nein ich bin keine
sorge ich halte abstand ja aber genau
das meine ich dass wir halten hier 150
abstand und in der u-bahn ist
gruppenkuscheln gesagt dass hätten das
für maßnahmen also erst mal müssen
maßnahmen nicht perfekt sein um
vernünftig zu sein
politik muss abwägen einkaufen zur
arbeit waren unbedingt notwendig
restaurant und kino leider nicht jede
kontakt reduzierung hilft und mal ganz
ehrlich so ein paar monate ohne saufen
tut dir vielleicht auch mal ganz gut
ich fange jetzt schon mittags abzusaufen
9 uhr mittags die innenstädte sind vor
weihnachten knallvoll aber live musik
ist verboten das fühlt sich ungerecht an
aber erstens essen kaufen ist achtung
wortspiel
essentiell zweitens wie lange bist du im
supermarkt ein tiefkühl pizza und bier
holen bezahlen wieder raus 15 minuten
maximal und neben keinem anderen
menschen stehst du länger als vielleicht
zwei minuten stichwort verweildauer
virologen sagen die kritische marke sind
15 minuten drin mit anderen menschen
dann wird es gefährlich auf einem
konzert atmest do 23 stunden rum bei
wagners götterdämmerung über vier
stunden sogar wagner kennst du ja klar
aber ich nehme lieber die tonne von rich
zeigt sie bei spotify ihre stunden und
15 minuten später
[Musik]
geile scheiße kapitel 2 leben bedeutet
mehr als arbeiten und einkaufen das
meine ich wir lassen die kultur sterben
es geht doch hier nur noch um job und
shoppen ich bin aber mehr als nur
kreditkarte irgend und arbeitsbiene ohne
kunst und kultur verkümmern wir als
gesellschaft
ich habe im letzten jahr auf 3 reggae
festivals verzichtet auf 3 was hat bitte
götter gabba gabba gabba mit kunst zu
tun wir verblöden langsam hier meine
freunde zum beispiel die macht ihr da
nur noch kurze hose geht doch nicht das
muss dahin gehen
das ist für mich auch schon anja ist
langweilig keine klubs nicht ins
restaurant war das jetzt wirklich zitat
das härteste weihnachten dass sie
nachkriegsgeneration je erlebt hat wie
armin laschet oder der londoner
bürgermeister gepumpt haben ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher die menschen im
hungerwinter 1946 hätten gerne noch
masken getragen und aufs kino verzichtet
das meine ich rede vom grundgesetz
artikel 12 ich habe das für recht meinen
beruf und mein arbeitsplatz frei zu
wählen und genau das mache ich jetzt ich
gehe da raus ich bin ich schauspieler
kapitel 3 ich poche auf meine
grundrechte dies jens spahn ich da vor
mir sehe die maske mir zugewendet bravo
bravo das theater bleibt trotzdem zu es
gibt leider kein grundrecht mit dem
beruf seiner wahl jederzeit geld zu
verdienen
mein traumberuf bleibt mir auch immer
verwehrt ich warte pantomime seien echt
quatsch gegen korona haben wir extra das
infektionsschutzgesetz verbessert damit
wir besser durch pannen kommen
landesregierungen dürfen events
verbieten kneipen schließen masken
pflicht anordnen ich würde dir das
schauspielen einfach so verbieten aber
das geht leider nicht das ist doch ein
grundrecht ja aber auch grundrechte
können in krisen eingeschränkt werden du
möchtest im falle einer kurve der
erkrankung noch verhandelt werden oder
bei einem unfall
deshalb sagen wir als gesellschaft auch
naja was weiß ich dass es nicht gut ist
nach napoli wein und 3 wagner mit
verbundenen augen roller zu fahren ist
das jetzt eine einschränkung deiner
grundrechte oder
das virus schränkte er ein und nicht die
politik wenn man das glück hat in
deutschland zu leben mit unserem
gesundheitssystem und unseren freiheiten
ist das eigentlich nur lächerlich von
diktatur zu reden
ich kann die aber gerne ein praktikum
beim gesundheitsministerium im iran
besorgen oder in turkmenistan ist das
mein letztes bier
alles andere wäre eine einschränkung
meiner grundrechte kapitel 4 dieses
ewige hin und her und alle machen es
besser so eine scheiße jetzt also wieder
wochenlang zu hause rum hin zu ostern
wieder lockern dann wieder lockt das
hätte keinen spaß keiner hat eine
langfristige strategie ja wie auch ist
für uns alle die erste kompanie wenn du
mit dem auto auf dem baum zuerst dann
bremst du ja auch sagt er nicht ich
bleibe es erst wenn ich eine
langfristige strategie ab oder dieses
hin und her
die ganze zeit gilt hier das eine und
das andere in nrw
da durfte ich ohne quarantäne aus dem
risiko gebiet einreisen in hessen nicht
am anfang weil man sich nicht mal
darüber einig ob das überhaupt was
bringen dass sich wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse ändern gehört dazu das
unterscheidet wissenschaft von attila
hildmann
apropos ich schenk dir sein neues buch
zum geburtstag
es heißt mein mann ich hab das gefühl
alle anderen machen es mehr sein
südkorea taiwan singapur nur wie hier
sind die korona doofen klar
funktionieren andere staaten besser in
südkorea überwacht die regierung deine
kreditkarten in taiwan
strecken sie dein handy ob der pilz oder
nicht und in singapur gibt es 20 stock
hebel wenn du gegen den baum pinkls auch
ohne corona die länder bewundert so regt
sich aber hier über jede maßnahme auf
kapitel 5 und überhaupt die korona app
ist ein scheiß drauf was mit den
kommunen
typisch deutsch sei teuer bringt gar
nichts ok bei software sind die asiaten
besser als wir
wenn deutschland die xbox erfunden hätte
es wahrscheinlich immer noch so aus
genau ich bekomme keine push nachricht
wenn ich eine risiko begegnung hatte ich
erfahre niemals wo die begegnung war das
ist die schlechteste software sei keine
ahnung windows 95
die app ist nicht perfekt das stimmt
aber sie hilft schon weil sie uns
täglich daran erinnert kontakte zu
reduzieren darauf kommt es an weniger
leute treffen weniger schön
sag mal bist du gerade zufällig bei
kindern ja klar die politiker sind schon
ja da ist immer einfach aber dabei kommt
es auch auf jeden einzelnen an
ist ja auch eigentlich nicht so schwer
kontakte runter maske anziehen und
bisschen abstand halten
kapitel 6 das leben der so schön wenn
die ganzen leute nicht gäbe wenn alle so
konsequent wie ich mache alles richtig
das glaubt jeder nennt sich bettet an
average verzerrung der mine automatisch
besser als der durchschnitt zu sein beim
autofahren bei der arbeit beim sex ich
bin definitiv besser als der
durchschnitt bei 6
ich sage in ein paar jahren gucken wir
zurück und sagen haben doch eigentlich
ganz gut hingekriegt
wir müssen da einfach ein bisschen
durchhalten bis genug menschen geimpft
deswegen sind da sind unsere enkel an
altersschwäche gestorben meine was auch
immer noch keiner wer wann wie wo dran
ist
bis dahin bleiben wir halt noch
vorsichtig alle menschen sind
potenzielle spender auch familie und
freunde man denkt ja immer bei leuten
die ich gut kenne stecke ich mich nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gesundheit ist die luft rein ist alles
tolle aerosole
wir müssen durch löw ich bewegte mich
hier nicht weg auf gar keinen fall
ok pass auf ich gehe durch lüften und du
erklärst den leuten das mit dem abo und
ihr daumen den quatsch heute ist mir
scheißegal was ihr macht ich habe ganz
andere sorgen